is a transgender activist
Jeffrey Marsh he's gone viral I think he
thinks he's a woman
or he thinks that he's neither a man nor
a woman but he dresses sort of like a
woman Jeffrey Marsh has gone viral with
a tick tock addressed specifically two
little boys and girls in which he makes
the argument that there is no such thing
as boys and girls
hi kids
or a girl
and I can prove it
so gather around the family and the
parents everybody answer my questions
you either say boys or girls who's
usually taller
oh boys okay but you've met some short
boys right you met some tall girls so
usually boys are taller but not always
okay who likes the color pink is
girls okay
um but you've met girls who don't like
pink and you met boys who do like pink
so usually girls like pink but not
always
everything you can think of that makes a
boy or makes a girl
is usually but not always
some of them are not even usually
where does that leave you
free you get to like what you like you
get to be who you are
maybe you're even like me and you're not
a boy or a girl
so obviously very confused man and a
very creepy man and he should not be
allowed within 300 yards of children but
his argument is not coherent either
his argument is ultimately
self-defeating it's a nice book end of
the show you open up with John fetterman
and Joe Biden you end with this guy I'm
not sure who the least coherent one is
the reason his argument is
self-underminding is not because he's
wrong about the color pink
he's right about that some boys like
pink some girls don't like pink it's not
because he's wrong about height it's
true there are some shirt boys and there
are some tall girls that's all true
the reason his argument is
self-underminding is because he
addresses it to boys and girls
and he doesn't just say hey boys and
girls I'm going to show you that there's
no such thing as boys and girls
but
because that could be sort of ironic or
with a little little wink and a
tongue-in-cheek it's the fact that
throughout the whole argument the
argument relies on the categories of
boys and girls
the very fact that he says there are
some short boys and there are some tall
girls
presumes that there are boys and girls
the very fact that he says some boys
like pink and some girls don't like pink
presumes that there are boys and girls
the very fact that these people refer to
trans women as a distinct category from
women
tell shows you that there is a
distinction between the boys who think
that they're women that call themselves
trans women and the girls who think that
they're men who call themselves trans
men and boys and girls are different the
very fact that there are these
ontological categories
the libs are right that there is such a
thing as gender expression
of course there is but they with the
thing they can't get away from is that
ontological reality that there are boys
and girls and even if a boy likes pink
and even if a boy is a little bit short
and even if a little boy likes to play
with Barbies or has the sort of
disordered sexual desires that that guy
has
they remain boys and girls because if
they didn't then his argument wouldn't
mean anything
right his the entire point he's trying
to make relies on the very existence of
boys and girls and then denying and
transgressing that thing that we all
know that we that we all can see before
our very eyes
it's it's a very shallow
argument that that he's making
but it's an argument that cannot be made
because if we even have meaningful
language then there's there's no way to
even refer to the things that he's
referring to without granting the the
very assistance of boys and girls that
he's trying to deny it cannot happen he
you can't run away from this reality and
it's a problem you see it in its
absolute extreme absurdity on the
transgender argument but it's on it's on
basically every big claim that the
Democrats are making leading into the
midterm elections they're they're making
arguments that just are not resonating
and they're not resonating because
they're incoherent their argument on
energy we have to shut down American
Energy because American energy is really
bad because it's destroying the
environment but that's destroying the
economy and it's causing record
inflation so we need to convince Saudi
Arabia to produce more energy and we've
got to sanction Russia so he stops the
war in Ukraine so that we get more
energy and and so that the global oil
prices go down but oil is bad but oil is
bad in America but it's not bad overseas
doesn't make sense it's where you get
John fetterman on the stage and he says
I'm I support fracking
previously you said you opposed fracking
yeah I uh I support fracking there's
just no answer on for the Democrats on
any of these issues we have to shut the
country down it's important kovitz going
to kill us all we have to keep the
schools closed I never said the schools
should be closed I never said that kovid
was that bad the the fauci ouchie it's
totally safe and totally effective no I
never said that that the fauciatchi was
totally safe and effective now it just
it's
they've just they've run out of
arguments and the people know it and
unless they steal this thing the people
are going to tell them
very clearly on Election Day you know
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss it this is woke
Wednesday my producer Ben Davies has
lined up an extremely woke PSA that's
really all he's told me about it from
Forbes you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
oh
foreign